>> [Music playing]
>> We live in a world of blurring boundaries,
between sectors of
industry, between known countries and territories.
Everything is changing.
>> The one global challenge that most people
around the world are
most worried about these days, namely climate
change, require new,
committed, and global problem solving alliances.
>> Countries are slowly becoming outdated.
They need to realize that their borders are
partial and that their
people and governments are one in the same.
>> Free education, universal education, and
free and universal
[unintelligible].
>> People need to start coming together, start
coming together as a
global community.
>> [Music playing]
>> Everyone together improving everyone else's
quality of life.
>> [Music playing]
>> And that's what should be done.
>> Together as a global community we have
the resources, we have the
intention, we have the skills, we have the
knowledge, and we have the
funds to transform Africa, to uplift the orphans,
and to heal the
sick.
>> I would look at a world going forward where
everyone has equal
opportunity, where you can provide equal chance
for your neighbor to
grow and to prosper.
>> [Music playing]